puny gods hey everybody I feel like
talking about marbles some more I'm
still kind of riding the high from
infinity war a bit and yeah I want to do
my list for the top 10 best MCU Marvel
Cinematic Universe villains now unlike
when I did my ranking of the MCU films
where I did restrict it to just the
films and did not incorporate the
Netflix or the other TV shows here all
are welcome
so open into this are ours not just it's
the movies it's the TV shows it's
Netflix all of it any villain from
anything that is connected to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is eligible for
inclusion on this list so establishing
that there are very few restrictions and
ground rules let's get started with
number 10
Ultron from age of Ultron now this is
where I have to point out a praising of
the villain is not necessarily praising
out of the film I don't think age of
Ultron is that bad a movie honestly it's
just doesn't live up to the previous
film and in addition to that it you know
its component parts don't quite fit
together but one of its big strengths is
James Spader
voicing Ultron he really does work as
this your testicle AI version of Tony
Stark
basically cuz he's got that same sort of
sense of of course I'm right I'm the
smartest guy in the room I know exactly
what I'm doing and being just kind of
snarky about it and you really see that
emphasize but he actually faces off with
snark I didn't snark Stark God but that
was another that was really appropriate
for Dean stuff against Stark about
midway through the movie and they're
like they're practically finishing each
other's sentences
but there's also there's also hints of
something a little deeper because he
seems genuinely pained when Scarlet
Witch and Quicksilver abandoned his
cause and unfortunately I feel like that
was an L
that probably was more explored before
the film got cut up for the final edit
because you can tell there are things
missing from there but I still think
that the power of the performance really
does carry this through not about number
ten but I do feel that it warrants
placement on the list number nine ego
the Living Planet played by Kurt Russell
in guardians of the galaxy vol 2 this
guy is a great villain for a number of
reasons he is once you get the scope of
what it is he's doing on the grand scale
in terms of the threat he presents but
also the damage that he's done on a
personal level to Peter Quill's
specifically then he makes very
wonderfully hateable villain and they
really did do a great job of having him
embody his name ego he is so full of
himself that he believes nothing else in
the universe is worthy to be anything
other than converted into just more of
him because he is the greatest thing
ever and and everything else in the
universe should be like him and that
works really well it really feeds into a
lot of the themes of the film as a whole
in terms of a lot of the family dynamics
and relationships that are really at the
heart of that film and he just his
reveal as a villain feels right and then
to see everyone join together to fight
him is so cathartic just watching them
all together you know from it give them
flying around just shooting up the
interior bits of the planet to quill
punching it out with him to when he
first just starts blasting him after he
confesses to having killed quills mother
to group blowing up the the brain it
yeah I know he's a good villain because
I enjoy watching him defeated so much
number eight hella from Thor Ragnarok
this is largely down to the performance
because the character on paper is
generic goddess of death secret sibling
with a grudge like it's I mean it's very
much in keeping with the kind of
overblown operatic that the Thor series
has gone for but it's not particularly
deeper than honestly the sort of twist
that went on with Loki in terms of you
know
oh he's not even really your brother
he's actually this like it feels very
much born out of a similar attempt at
overblown family drama but Cate
Blanchett in this part her her sense of
untouchability like she really just
strolls in with a confidence that makes
you think we really don't have a chance
against her do we she exudes that and
she I and she lives up to it as well in
the actions he's and that headdress holy
crap it takes a lot to have a costume
and a look that extreme and to not have
the performance be buried underneath it
it takes a really strong performer to
still shine through that and she does
absolutely and again her smugness makes
it all the more rewarding when she is
defeated number seven and I'm gonna get
heat for this one but I'm hoping I can't
explain it in a way that will kind of
ease that heat off a little bit
number seven is Loki now before you all
jump up on me
I love Loki Loki is great but here's the
thing Loki was really only the flat-out
villain twice in the numerous
appearances that he's had and that was
original Thor and Avengers the first one
appearances since then Thor the dark
world thor ragnarok infinity war he is
an antihero he is maybe he's not a good
guy but he's not a villain in the story
he's not an antagonist in the story he's
not something that is impeding the
heroes he's all he's that in the
minority of his appearance is 40% is he
actually the villain and that's why I'm
not gonna put our hand high
because I actually think a lot of his
best stuff was when he was out of velum
Onan into antihero mode so this is me
judging him as a villain not as a
character so I'm hoping I got some
leeway on that and the other reason he's
not hire is if I'm being completely
honest in the first Thor while it did
lay all the groundwork we kind of needed
to understand where he was coming from
and what motivated him as a villain he's
not as much fun in Avengers he's fun he
is really embracing and enjoying messing
with these guys he's not just being
wicked he's reveling in it and that is
what makes him so great as a villain but
funnily enough he doesn't really lose
that when he stops being an out-and-out
villain he still revels in mischief he's
just not the big problem they have to
deal with and later appearances but I do
I do like Loki a lot but when I actually
charred him as a character and what I
liked most about him his his strictly
Louganis villain work this is as high as
he gets number six Ward from agents of
shield now this was an interesting
progression because Ward initially was
one of the things I hated about the
first season of agents of shield I
really he was so wooden and so generic
and I'm like why is this guy even here
like he's not nominally a better fighter
than than someone like May he doesn't
like he'd like why is even here he just
seems so generic and then to have it
revealed that he's a traitor
which initially I was very skeptical of
because I had assumed that when we got
to the second season and you know he
came back then inevitably he'd win their
trust back cuz he looked like he had
doubts about what he was doing and like
maybe he was only with Hydra cause he
was he was behind and he was loyal to
that one guy and maybe he's not a true
believer and so I was expecting to see
him get a Redemption arc in the second
season and I knew like there's this
should not be redeemed for what he did
to the level of betrayal he did to this
group he should not be allowed to be
redeemed but I didn't try and redeem him
not only did they not try and redeem him
second season they doubled down on how
this guy is he started showing up and
instead of softening like and trying to
trying to make it his betrayal seemed
not that bad they just start to peel
back the layers that this guy is so much
worse than you even thought he was after
he betrayed the rest of the team and I
loved it I look and it retro actively
made his first season stuff way better
it was so painful to watch at the time
and that is still a fault of that first
season but it suddenly makes sense of
course he was generic he was playing a
part
it was just cover he it was to his
benefit to be generic and not really be
noticed so it's just such a phantasm
transformation and to watch him you know
the way he throws off the a the the
shield agents he's he's so often a wild
card on all of this stuff going on he's
a monkey wrench that gets thrown into
everybody's things pursuing his own
stuff I loved it and his exit from the
series is also big one of the big reason
why I bowed out he's it's not
exclusively that this was the point at
which I go well I'm done but my interest
level dropped and then when I fell
behind I just I didn't feel the
motivation to catch up so in season
three when they killed him and had a
really really really super generic big
evil threat walking around with his face
I did not care so hard because Ward was
awesome okay now top five let's go -
what Conda and let's talk kill monger
played by Michael B Jordan Soho oh boy
there's a lot to like about kill monger
so first of all very much a legitimate
threat to T'Challa as a one
combatant and also the level of
knowledge that he has about Wakanda to
be able to work the system in order to
basically just get into burn it down
because that's all that he's about but
at the same time the key to his rage the
key to his anger being very legitimate
between both a being a legitimate wrong
that was done to him by two chaka two
challahs father
coupled with him having a perspective on
what conda's isolationism that is not
invalid and so that that right off the
bat helps a lot it was also really cool
to watch him initially appear to be
maybe a high-level henchman at best kind
of a partner with the villain we already
knew with Klaw and for him just to gun
the guy down you know around a halfway
through the movie and then drag his body
as his free ticket into a Conda oh yeah
they talk about arriving as a villain oh
that was good and again his his rage not
only is Michael B Jordan really good at
exuding that kind of frustration and
anger and channeling it into a
performance but it felt also like that's
what the character was doing like the
character had a goal but he he seemed to
know that rage was his fuel and it was
never too far from him but he wasn't
just shouting and angry all the time
like he he had a plan he had nuances and
he was a fantastic villain number four
the vulture Adrian Toomes played by
Michael Keaton in spider-man homecoming
this guy is great for a lot of reasons
first off this is exactly the kind of
spider-man villain that I want I
actually would say that I've kind of
wanted from the beginning and because I
feel like especially after the very
first spider-man film the first Sam
Raimi one they had a tendency to go too
big with the villains so as much as I
love
Doc Ock in spider-man 2 that started a
trend of these villains being big
citywide threats and I always like the
friendly neighborhood spider-man the guy
who's dealing with a criminal who's not
big enough to warrant the involvement of
any other heroes and the vulture is that
ultimately he's just an arms dealer he's
an arms dealer with access to some
pretty scary stuff but he's just an arms
dealer The Avengers aren't gonna crack
down on this guy and so it falls to
spider-man so he is the right scale that
I wanted to see spider-man take on and
he's also the kind of thing that that
spider-man 3 tried to do with Sandman
and failed at but a guy who's he doesn't
have these big sinister ambitions just
trying to make a living he's doing it
illegally and he should eat he deserves
to be caught but he's he's just in it
for the money yet at the same time
Michael keep playing I mean you never
doubt that this guy is dangerous and
that scene in the car when he is working
it out who Peter is and then turns
around to confront him you saved my
daughter I will never forget that but if
you get in the way of my business that
will be the end of you it's so chilling
Lee played its it is a well conceived
character well realized visually it's an
awesome look and with a just a terrific
performance by a really well cast actor
number 5 Wilson Fisk
the kingpin as played by Vincent
D'Onofrio took me a second I lost it for
a moment there haha but oh man he is a
big part of what is so good about that
first season a veritable he's not the
only thing that's good but he's one of
the big big things that's really good
because we first of all he exudes power
he exudes menace just standing there you
you just see this guy in the room
like okay down nervous and you should
and the way that he is played and the
the little bits of nuance like I know I
love his courtship of in his
relationship with Vanessa to see that
and to see that he legitimately cares
about her and that he's finding a
connection for possibly the first time
in his life like that and but at the
same time he's that does not in any way
soften him and it will never undercut
his ruthlessness because she's not ever
gonna try and change that part of him
and how just methodical and determined
this is a guy who was risen to power on
sheer force of will and it it takes a
lot of presence and a lot of I was gonna
say charisma but charisma implies a
likeability I'm not I'm not sure that
Fisk as the character is charismatic but
the performance is just imbued with so
much quiet strength that you buy that
through sheer force of will this guy
rose up to become the kingpin of Hell's
Kitchen
it's an astoundingly intimidating
performance and it's amazing we are
getting right up towards the top these
top two I had a really really really
hard time figuring out the ranking of
and in fact just before shooting this I
flipped it and maybe if I came back and
maybe if it was another day maybe if I
shot this tomorrow maybe I would put it
back but today this is the way of going
so number two battles oh man it is no
small accomplishment what they did with
Thanos I honestly I was expecting to
like infinity war I was excited for
infinity war but I I did honestly think
in the back of my head they are not
gonna be able to do anything that
totally lives up to six years worth of
buildup since he first appeared at the
at the main credits and the first
Avengers
like there's it's not possible to live
up to that level of anticipation of
build but they did it and they did it by
making the movie about him because all
the other years were already established
so instead we zero in on him and we
understand one of these is he's trying
to accomplish why he thinks it's a good
idea what about is driving him and has
has galvanized his this thinking and why
he is so certain that he's right and
then to see the lengths that he's
willing to go to in order to accomplish
this we get a look at a nuanced maniac
cuz he is the mad Titan what he is doing
is insane
but we understand why he's doing it how
many goals can you say that about how
many villains act like in a way that is
like no that's that is that is that is a
crazy person's conclusion but we
understand why they came to that
conclusion and it's not like some stupid
contrived like misunderstanding or or
some crap like that like we know exactly
why he thinks this is what has to be
done and it's hope and josh brolin who's
an actor who doesn't really do much for
me most of the time he brings such
menace but also pathos to this character
and when something is difficult for him
you see it in the performance through
the motion capture that this is a
difficult thing for him to do like weed
all the stuff with the soulstone you see
that this is not easy for him and that
it weighs on him even after that's a
bold writing state and writing thing to
do and that is an impressive piece of
performance to be able to pull that off
thanos did in fact manage to live up to
that much hype but he's not taking the
top spot the top spot ultimately I have
to give to the guy who is not only an
amazing villain a perfect counterpoint
to the hero a perfect in bold
of the thematic elements of the story in
which he is being used wonderfully just
enjoyable watching him finally get
defeated perfectly hateable
I have to give it to David Tennant as
kilgrave in season 1 of Jessica Jones I
love the first season of Jessica Jones
unabashedly I like if I could cut an
episode and a half out of it because
there's like a little flabbiness towards
the end it would be damn near perfect
and killgrave is one of the reasons for
that because when you're doing a show
that is ultimately about themes of abuse
and survival of it and of the power that
an abuser can continue to hold over you
even after you know they they did the
wood they've already done the worst of
it that they're going to do to you this
is such a perfectly realized the Matic
villain so often you know the villains
are just how do we make something that
is hard for the heroes to overcome and
kilgrave is that but he feeds into every
theme that is going on to the show and
enhances it all with this walking
embodiment of entitlement everything is
supposed to go his way and if it doesn't
go his way
well he has a power that ensures that
he's gonna make it go his way doesn't
matter what anybody wants and he is
willing to kid himself into believing
that when he tells someone something
that they that they'll then say back to
him yes that's what I want that he'll
take it as an affirmation he'll take it
as truth because that's what he wants to
believe he doesn't care about people's
actual wants actual needs he only cares
about his own rationalizing his own
justifying his own and making sure that
it happens and not caring
about the damage ever and it is a
perfect way to handle a villain for what
this story was about what this carrot
what the character of Jessica Jones was
being used to represent and be
emblematic of this is in my mind a
perfectly realized villain and I have to
give kilgrave the top spot on this but
that's my ranking what is yours who do
you think is the best villain in the MCU
or do you want to do a full top 10
whatever your thoughts are and of course
your thoughts on my top 10 you know all
that stuff drop something down in the
comments let's talk about there's all
this stuff to do you throw me on patreon
like subscribe follow me on Twitter bla
bla bla
links in the description and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]